>>> THIS IS NEWVIANAL
D KINGDOM, A STAT
THIS IS HOW ITEVN'CONCERNED FOM.
>> CNN HAS JUSAT
PRINCE CHE DUCHESS
OF CORNWALL HA TRAVED  BE UEEN T
MAX, INFORMATION HAS BEEN COMING
IN HERE.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US THINK HAVEO
LOLANGUAGE, THE PALACE
HAVE TO PUT OUTEMENTS FROM BAL.
IT IS A VERY PRIVATE ESTATE.
NOLYE MEDICAL CONDTHEY SEE IT AN
AND WHAT THEY  TS AT THE DOCTORT
LANGUAGE FROM PALACE.
WOULDN'T NORMALLY
ANYTHING LIKE THU  REFERENCE TO,
FRANKLY.
SHRES UNDER MECA
SHE'S AT THE CASTLE.
S BEEN
PI
SOEDICAL EVE
READ INTO WHAT THAT MEAN I
MEHE
NCABOUT HER HEALTH, BUT SHSUPER
BE HOSPITA I
KNOW WHAT THATBUT THERE
OUTHAT
OTHER OPTIC  I THE L.
PRIMS TWEENG ABOUT
AATHER THAN
TRO KEEPN ANNOUNCED  P
, THE QUEEN'S HEIR, IS
, TRYING MMEDIATELY TOORAL IOT S
C
TO SEE WHAT PRINCE WILLIAM'S MOS
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY  B.
'RHE
FAMILY HE ORMED.
BUIN WILSO
SURE BE EXPECTO VISI
WELL., REMINDOFVE ERE SHE WAS S
AND  CONCERNS VE ARISEN ASW YS
O BALMORALGO T
SUMMER.
AND SHE ALWAYSO
BUCKGHACE TO
IME MINISTER.
AND THE ERN RECENTLY
THHE
BE RETURNI FROM BAO
APPOINT THNISTER, SO
THE  AND INCOMING PRIME
MINISTERS HA TE
SHOKFRAIL.MORAL TO HAVE THE CE .
S STANDING, SO IO CONCERNED ABO
I DID  NIGHT
WHENOT MESSAGE TSAS ING OFHE
COUNCIL, WHICH IS THIS ANCIENT
INSTITUTION,ERL TO
ISTION.
A MEETING THAT TN WAS DUE HAIR M
FRL ANAS A
VERY IMPNTNG BECAUSE
IT WASING IN L TRUSSS
PRIME MINISTER, BUT ALSO  PRIVY
ONT COUNCIL.
CANCELESO W
MACO WAS IN A SITUATE A
CANCELEDVIA ZO.
T ANY MORE UPDATES
.
LOF RUMORS THIS
MORNING ABQUEEN NG
CONCERNED WHEN ITA HEARINGFALL .
I JUST HAD AS I'
SPNSINGTON PAL
E OFS TO BALMORAL.DU
IMMEDIATELY,ANCELINGRINCE S, BO
EVERYTHING TORALLET'S JUST PUT
CONTEXT, THE ABO
PRINCE WILLIAM WAS HIS KIDS'
FIRST DAY CHOOL.SO HE'DRT
SCHOOL, HEEAO N. FROM
O, SAWG WITH TRUSS, SHE
APPEARED HAPPY, SH H
SO THE CANE, BUT TO
ACTUALLYN
ONE OF TSETOS.
THERE WAE THN THOUGH UR SOURCESE
SEEMS TO BE PERHAPS SOME SOFTH S
OBAT
ANL LIKE THAT.S TE
ED WASN'T
MOI AT.MEAN, THSU
.ADOMENT TO GLANCE
ACROSS ALL OF THIT
NETWOR AGE.
AN I WOULD SAYYOU ,
WHEN THE H
BEFORE, WE GET A SUBTLE
FROM THEAC
DOWN ANDE  BAUDI
RIAT THEWOS -- WHAT THE
PALACE IS DOING ISING THISE ROLP
WHICH ING IN
LET'S BE TRANSPARENT OU
WHAT IS HAPPENING D WHATS IS
WED THAT THE F WALES ANF
NO GO OR CAS
E QUEEN IN SCOTLD
D THE CASE OWILLIAM, HE WAS
CHILD THE FIRST DAY OF SH HIS
A STATEMAX, HING E WITH THE QUEE
MIICE.
IL LANGUAGE TVE NOT HEARDORE.LV
NOT SEEN BINE
HEALTH OF THD QUEEAT IY  YOU
LOOKED AROUND AND YOITISH MEDIAN
COVERAGE NOW.
THAT'S WHY YING AROUND
AND SE CU ARINN.
THIS IS -- WDON'T KNOWHAS  HAPPI
IN
FULFILL DUTIES, THISLDA
SIMPLE SCARE AND THINGS GE
THIS IS AS OW SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE NOSEORE,>> N
LET'SK ATHESTAS HERE.
IT IS THAT THE QUEEN MAY BE
UN TT THOSE DUTIESSH OLDS
HAVE TO GET READE
STS, ULARLY WHEN THE
PHOTOGRAPHERS ARE IN.
SHE'S TIRED AND MAY NOT BEBL
THINK THAT WHAT WOULD HAPP
IN TT SITUAT WOULD
INLORS OF STATE, ARE PRIMARILY
EY'RE CALLED, LEGA GIV PARTICUL
DUTIES, SOOMLS WITH RLIAMENT, S.
SO TMIHING T HAPPENIER
IT CLDE SOMETHING E
BROAD, W I WE CALL A
REGENCY, WHICH
QUOF HER
CHAT'S QUITE A C
PROCESS.
THERE IS A COMMITT THAT
AGREED, H?M NOT QUITE SURE.
BUT WEE HE QUEEN I
COMFORTABLE.
SO N THAT IT IRE
ABS ST  IS SOMNG SERIOUS  ANDRR
LANGUAGE OF THENT, T TR TWO IMDL
QUEEN'S HEALTH,
ONWE NEVER TOLISSUE?
ABOUT PRINCE
EX MAY NEVER KNOW E UNDERLYING E
ANDING T DAY,
S IN GOOD HEAH G HER AGE.
I DO WANT TO BRING IN DR. S  YOS
GU CONVERSATION. WE VEFORMATIONO
THAT THEUEOC
ERNED, BUT THEY HAVE
RECOMMENDED SHE REMAIN DI
KNAGE, KNOWING SOMOF
POTENTIALLY REMAIN TATLT W WD S
SUPERVISION FOR?
WHAT ARE THE OF
IBILIT
ITTY LONG LIST.
HAT IS D
THERE JUHEWELL.
SHE'S 96THE QUEEN.
IFOM INDICATION OFSCULAREART/LUH
BUT, YOU- IT NDS ON HOW THE
THI READ THE STATEMENT, G FUHET
FIRST OF ALL, THAT WAS THE FIRST
F THE AT SO THAT
SORT OF MEANT THERE WAS A LITTLE
BIT OF A CRESCENDOTHIS
EVALUATING, NOWE RTEVALUATING,
THE BEGINNING THEYHT, HEY,
IT IS A LITTLE BUT
NOT ENOUGH TO TRIGGETHT
OF STATEMENT.
UPONURRE
IS CONCERN.
SOE
INITIAL EVALUA ANDHIADNOW AND I
TPOINT.
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THERE WAS
SOME SORFIC EVENT,  A FAL G, SO,
THE HEART, KNO S
OFHI
T WANT TSPULINGS BECAUSE
PUTS IT OUT THERNDE DON'T T IT
INTERESTING THAT THEY RELE
AT
TIME WE KNOW I WHE
SHE HAS GONEE EV DETAILS
ABOUT WHAT THE HOSTAL VISIT
S OUT,TELL YOUSHE WAS GOING TO A
THAT I I
SEEMS, FM WHAT I'M H
AND I THINTHAT'S AN IMPORTANT
POINT.
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY THA
MEANS, BUT AT LEAST
POINT IT SEEMS THEOCE
LIKE WE CABE ADDRESS IT
T LEAST ADEQUATEESS IT WITHO
SPITAL.
MY GUESSS THAT, YOU KNOW, SHE
HAS FACILITIES THAT ARE QUITE
EXPEE BLE TO
HOTHERE ARE CERTN ,
YOU KNOW, MORE INTENSIVE CARE
AITAL.
BREATHING, TW, THINGS THAT
THAT ASSIST WITH MAINTAINIODREGS
WHETHER THEY'RE